I feel like you're gonna like this and
it's it's different
to stuff we normally watch okay it is
it's kind of similar to that guy that
walks in the car dealership and like
pretends like he works there oh okay
it's that style okay hidden camera all
right
but it's it's like you know I like my
name Victoria yeah I like tasteful
hidden camera videos where it's like no
one is harmed it's just like no one's
like a victim it's just like funny
interactions you know
um so this is
a new version of Bobby Holliday yeah I
mean it's like the industrial version Oh
I will say sorry I'm late man oh this
guy yep
what are you talking about Johnny
I don't know what you're talking about
bro
who's running this [__] who's all the
gross yeah you got his number yeah put
him on the phone please
I'm Johnny ham check I got the six and a
half inch cables that you guys need okay
finish this [__] job nobody ever
knows what the [__] going on in this
business you know yeah
hey Siri call Josh gross one of the one
of the comments that's like the top
comment was like 30 seconds in and we
already have Josh gross on the phone
yeah Legend yeah
hey Josh you got uh uh what is it hand
checked ham check here with some six
inch cables or something six and a half
you know what we're talking about
yeah a guy named hint a guy named Josh
it's Johnny it's Johnny ham check what
are you up to
still running this [__] or what
yeah Steve
Steve
yeah well he's the one that sent me over
here and I got a backpack full of
[__] cables and I need to give them
the what's your name again I'm gonna
give them to Kurt I just need you to put
it down that I dropped them off and tell
Balboni just tell Balboni that I'm done
working with him all right
do you know who this guy is Josh
what are you doing sleeping over there
it's me Johnny project manager
all right let me find out he might be in
the wrong place
later on
you sure it's for corner
Corner yeah no I'm looking for tough
Knuckles Tommy tough Knuckles out of New
York City uh you're in the wrong place
no we're with cornica closing the guy
I'm looking for looks exactly like it
yeah
four foot one he's got the same wiry
city you see why he said you do up time
same wiring [__] you do up top yeah yeah
I saw the one where he walked into that
guy in The Home Depot and was like ah
bash that dude's head in with a hammer
oh that was him yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so good it's handshake Mani is just the
perfect name I've never heard a name
more perfect than that did you see his
slot one though oh with the guy dude
with the crazy eyes yeah yeah yeah yeah
that thing I can't believe we never
watched that on the show I felt bad
yeah I don't know that dude was tweaking
out of his head
it's it's very us though it is
the slot scraper that's it that's him
right there that's it
yeah yeah sure maybe yeah there's
nothing to listen to I'm just worried
about the audio listeners man all right
let me commentate this for you all right
so
um the opening frame if you're listening
on audio
um it's a big dick in balls no uh if you
ever like wanted to walk into a person's
RGB keyboard that's what it looks like
there's a little man in there
uh it basically looks like one of us
with a with a dad hat sitting in front
of a slot machine all right so Johnny
ham check is approaching the what is
soon to be uh you know discovered is the
slot scraper
so he's smacking the top of the machine
rubbing the screen he's doing circles on
the screen
and then spin away
come on
what a seasons
he's getting frustrated that he's not
hitting the bonuses
when they do show up
[Music]
see yeah
yeah
so I think this guy has taken at least a
half gram of methamphetamine yeah and I
think what he thinks he can do is push
the it's a it's a digital slot machine
and every time the real spin I think he
thinks he can push the Reel back up
no it's not that he's just doing it
because it's like a lucky thing I
thought he was doing it because it looks
like when the bonus comes down and if
it's like traveling past the bottom I
thought he'd sort of push it back up I
know I think he's rubbing the things for
luck got it got it like once the bone
you know like once three rows show up
and you're like [__] I only need one
more row that's why he's doing that yeah
let me see one let me see this
he's scraping it Cody would know because
Cody's also a slot this is what I'm
saying I feel that I'm like of mentally
I've been here before you know
hey
you know what's funny is like I
empathize with him because
like Johnny Hampshire is kind of like
chirping him a little bit Yeah comes up
he's like you haven't had [__] yet yeah
if I was that guy be so pissed yeah of
course [__] is this yeah don't get out
of here dude you're ruining my luck the
scraping was working before now it's not
because you're chirping me
those guys going there he is
scraping the screen dude oh he is up on
it man
okay so just quickly the same way like
smeagle looks at the ring that's how
this guy looks at the slot screen if
you're listening on audio
uh it's your drunken Uncle who stopped
eating in 1988 and just only can switch
to math yeah switch to a little like
occasional myth
occasional pookie I'm not gonna say math
you know he's just a little Pooky hit
and then
and then uh
um beer and cigarettes this is diet and
now he's hinging this man this is pure
addiction you gotta get the last the
last frame here
ah
oh [__]
wait did he is that a hit is that why
he's doing that I think his face kind of
says who Do You Think You Are I Am yeah
the slot scraper now has uh made eye
contact with Johnny ham check and Johnny
ham check I think he puts on like you
know he's a guy that's on phase but I
bet you if we interviewed Johnny
Hampshire
yeah out of all his moments [__] I would
I would wager this one Johnny ham check
would come clean and go yeah when he
looked at me like that I was I was
scared I was scared I think I barked up
the wrong tree
want to [__] with this guy no a guy
looking at me like this
dude I wouldn't even I wouldn't even let
him get his head turned I would see
those eyes from profile I'd be [__]
out of there you couldn't really see
them from profile though that no I won't
what I'm saying is he's like scraping
and they're kind of obfuscated and the
moment he's
if I got like a three-quarter angle of
those pupils I'd be out I'd be out
hit it
man ah what a rush that is yeah